[Musica]
attraversare lo specchio attraverso lo
specchio un concetto bellissimo e
complicatissimo ma con il quale abbiamo
tutti un po' di familiarità Innanzitutto
chi questa mattina si è alzato e si è
guardato allo specchio
immagino un po' tutti perché Perché
l'avete fatto perché vi siete Guardati
allo specchio questa mattina l'avete
fatto per vedere se eravate magari in
tono con i colori se la barba era giusto
magari vi siete Pettinati io no magari
vi siete Pettinati ma soprattutto
l'avete fatto per l'altro per l'altra
persona per lo sguardo delle altre
persone
noi
ci relazioniamo con gli altri
quotidianamente e gli altri sono la
nostra relazione e chi vuole in questo
momento faccia un piccolo esperimento
piccolissimo solo chi vuole guardatevi
un secondo negli occhi giratevi
guardatevi negli occhi chi a casa puoi
immaginare di guardare qualcuno negli
occhi o chiamare il marito la moglie e
guardare un attimo negli occhi qualche
secondo Ecco come vi siete sentiti Come
vi siete sentiti Ecco questo è il titolo
di una famosa canzone dei Clash Che
significa dovrei restare o dovrei
andarmene dovete sapere che questa cosa
ce l'abbiamo in comune con tutti gli
esseri viventi e qualcuno di voi in
questo momento stai dicendo Quasi quasi
dovrei andarmene oppure dovrei restare
questa domanda ce la facciamo
quotidianamente e nel farla cerchiamo
costantemente di uscire fuori da noi per
andare attraverso questo specchio e
grazie a Dio nel 1815 un 18 51 Scusate
un famoso
filosofo Arthur Schopenhauer racconta
questa cosa molto bene con il dilemma
del porcospino Schopenhauer ci racconta
che in una fredda notte d'inverno alcuni
porcospini si ritrovarono al freddo e
cercando di restare vicini per scaldarsi
vicendevolmente rischiarono come potete
immaginare di ferirsi vicendevolmente e
così trascorsero tutta la notte nel
tentativo di avvicinarsi e allontanarsi
l'uno dall'altro e questo creava in loro
la giusta distanza ora sappiate che ciò
a cui teniamo ci tiene solo le persone
che conosciamo bene possono in un
qualche modo avvicinarsi e ferirci ed è
per questo che possiamo immaginare tutti
quanti immaginate di uscire di qua e
vedere un tizio che passa
magari in bicicletta in monopattino e
scooter e riguarda e vi dice Vergogna
che cosa pensate se siete delle teste
calde come me probabilmente lo inseguite
oppure gli urlate a vostra volta se
siete tranquilli invece non dite proprio
nulla o probabilmente penserete che
quella persona si sia sbagliata che
quella persona si sia confusa
se io invece vi dicessi che quella
persona
non dipende da come vi sentite dal
vostro temperamento ma dipende
Se conoscete quella persona o meno
Pensate se passa vostro cugino Vostro
marito e vi urla vergogna in quel modo
lì come vi sentite di certo non vi
sentite bene
Ecco noi tendiamo ad imitarci
costantemente
gli altri sono il nostro specchio in
questo momento alcuni di voi stanno
sentendo addirittura la mia emozione
stanno sentendo in base alla velocità di
come parlo il loro respiro che cambia il
battito del cuore che cambia intensità
che cambia frequenza
questo lo facciamo costantemente Se io
parlo un po' più lentamente alcuni di
voi magari si addormentano
se parlo troppo velocemente vi mando in
agitazione e lo facciamo continuamente
lo sguardo degli altri è il nostro
specchio e sono anche un grande artista
come avete visto non l'hanno detto
sono anche un grande artista Questo è un
esperimento famosissimo di Eleanor
Gibson che è una psicologa americana la
quale fa un esperimento bellissimo lo
chiama esperimento del baratro
questo esperimento è fatto in questo
modo c'è un bambino come vedete
dall'altra parte un caregiver è in mezzo
un baratro di vetro il bambino
sappiamo che ha poche paure nella vita
una di queste quando nasce è proprio il
vuoto il vetro o meglio il vuoto non il
vetro Scusatemi Ecco che il bambino se
dall'altra parte non c'è nessuno arriva
gattona e si ferma ma se dall'altra
parte c'è la mamma che lo guarda
e gli sorride Ecco che il bambino
attraversa qualsiasi ostacolo se in
questo momento qualcuno vi sorride vi dà
una reazione completamente diversa
pensate che il sorriso lo sguardo degli
altri è in grado di farci sbandare
mentre camminiamo
che guardate Quando è entrato in un
locale chi guardi Guardi
se c'è un posto libero guardi se la
gente sorride Beh la maggior parte di
noi anzi tutti noi appena entriamo in un
locale guardiamo le facce tristi le
facce aggressive perché questo ci
consentirà di capire e di salvarci
eventualmente
poi subito dopo guardiamo le facce che
sono tranquille rilassate esattamente in
questo ordine qua gli sguardi degli
altri ci minacciano e ci nutrono Cosa
significa che uno sguardo Ti minaccia e
tinoso e ti nutri Scusate non ho più
saliva praticamente
significa che
esattamente in questo ordine quando tu
riesci a superare quello ostacolo il
primo potete portarmi un po' d'acqua per
cortesia Grazie
sono secco dalle emozioni Grazie
Ah ritorno a parlare tra come una
persona umana Scusatemi
la lascio qua guarda che non è
bellissima ma la lascio qua per
sicurezza per sicurezza
Ah ecco in questo momento io ho passato
quel un'attività di attacco fuga come ce
l'abbiamo tutti quando siamo emozionati
un piccolo spavento di attacco fuga che
poi dopo diventa un circuito
dell'accudimento ce l'abbiamo tutti
quanti Dentro ce l'avete anche voi
succede esattamente così come quando c'è
un terremoto arriva un terremoto ci
spaventiamo Si salvi chi può via bambini
gatti cani fuori dalla casa e poi
Immediatamente dopo Immediatamente dopo
aiutiamo il nostro vicino di casa che
non abbiamo mai visto prima magari a
scavare nelle macerie per giorni e
giorni e questo lo facciamo
continuamente lo facciamo talmente tanto
da non renderci conto che quando succede
Delle volte ci dimentichiamo di
attraversare lo specchio in base alle
persone che abbiamo di fronte immaginate
per un istante di venire con me a Padova
vi porto in un bar di Padova in un bar
di Pisa anche in un bar Universitario di
quelli che hanno pochi tavolini ma c'è
una fila sterminata per prendere
l'aperitivo Ecco immaginate di venire
con me Io vi dico tranquilli Tanto al
bar c'è il mio amico Michele Il mio
amico Michele ci servirà per primi io
arrivo guardo un mio amico Michele e
penso Meno male che c'è Michele che
almeno mi servirà per primo
Probabilmente dall'altra parte Michele
mi guarda e pensa Meno male che Gennaro
ci conosciamo da 20 anni e non se la
prenderà male se lo servo come tutti gli
altri magari anche per ultimo
capite che se io e Michele non parliamo
è un problema se io e Michele non ci
ascoltiamo vicendevolmente è un problema
questa cosa qui ve lo posso assicurare
questa abilità qui l'abilità di imparare
ad ascoltare le persone è un'abilità che
non ha mai fine cosa significa che per
tutta la vita potete andare talmente a
fondo nella capacità di ascolto delle
altre persone impariamo a farci più
domande O meglio fare più domande e fare
meno affermazioni Noi siamo talmente
tanto dentro la nostra testa cercare di
capire che cosa dobbiamo dire come
Dobbiamo dirlo che rischiamo molte volte
Appunto di non ascoltare le persone
accanto a noi
tutti quanti vogliamo attenzione e
scommetto che avete sentito che c'è
gente che fa di tutto per avere un like
sui social e tutti quanti Oggi c'è
questa moda eccetera ma la verità è che
la desiderabilità sociale esiste da
sempre o meglio esiste da quando
Esistono i gruppi umani perché perché
anche anticamente se voi foste stati
allontanati dal vostro gruppo di
riferimento avreste rischiato la vita e
dunque noi psicologi quando costruiamo
un questionario un test di personalità
dobbiamo proprio stare attenti alla
variabile della desiderabilità sociale
non so se voi avete questa
desiderabilità sociale Se vi capita ogni
tanto
l'attenzione di cui sto parlando in
questo momento è essenzialmente la cura
che data le cose in questo momento chi
di voi mi sta ascoltando con attenzione
trarrà un significato importante da
questo messaggio per lo meno trarrà il
suo significato Chi di voi è un po'
distratto sta pensando agli affari
propri avrà tutt'altra esperienza di
questo momento questa cosa qua vale per
ogni singola azione della nostra vita
per ogni piccola cosa che facciamo nella
nostra vita
e ora mi faccio una domanda un po'
particolare la persona che avete
guardato prima o la persona accanto a
voi voi sapreste che regalo farle
sapreste Che regalo fare a quella
persona perché se la vostra risposta è
sì io so esattamente Che regalo fare a
quella persona significa che le avete
dato questa giusta attenzione Se invece
la vostra domanda la vostra risposta è
boh chissà chiedo suo cugino chiamo la
sua amica allora probabilmente c'è
bisogno di ampliare questa capacità di
ascolto ponetevi questa domanda io che
regalo potrei fare a quella persona che
tipo di regalo potrei fare a quella
persona
la cura l'attenzione da valore alle cose
che ci circondano gli oggetti che ci
circondano immaginate un'auto un'auto se
la lasciate lì alle intemperie non le
fate il tagliando Non la portate dal
meccanico prima o poi quell'auto la
buttate via Se invece quell'auto lì
le date attenzione cosa diventa diventa
appunto un auto d'epoca diventa qualcosa
di realmente prezioso questo vale per
tutto vale per il tuo gatto vale per una
pianta Questo è molto banale che se non
curi appassisce molto velocemente ma
vale anche per quel libro per quello
studio per quella persona per quel
contesto e dunque iniziamo a spostare
intenzionalmente le nostre risorse
attentive in quella direzione nel
momento in cui noi iniziamo a dare
questo tipo di cura tutto inizia un po'
a cambiare e adesso
Vi chiedo per cortesia di ripetere
l'esperimento di prima di guardarvi con
questa consapevolezza riguardatevi un
secondo tra di voi
esattamente in questo modo osservatevi
In questo modo sentite un po' quella
sensazione che avete sentito prima ha un
piccolo trucco se siete docenti eccetera
Fate questo giochino qui e le persone si
sveglieranno all'improvviso perché
l'altro è l'attivatore emotivo più
potente che ci sia Sì qua fossi da solo
non avrei neanche la bottiglia d'acqua
in mano sicuramente
invece ci siete voi che siete
l'attivatore emotivo più potente che ci
sia e la relazione non è né dentro di me
né dentro di voi ma è tra di noi ed è
questa la magia della relazione ed è per
questo che dobbiamo imparare ad
ascoltare con attenzione le persone che
ci circondano e dunque Lasciatemi dire
una semplice cosa che se volete davvero
fare un regalo bello alle persone che vi
circondano alle persone che amate ma
anche ad uno sconosciuto che passa qua
davanti Dategli tutta la vostra
attenzione perché la vostra attenzione è
il regalo più bello che voi possiate
fare a voi stessi quando vi riguarderete
allo specchio e alle persone che vi
circondano Grazie per la vostra
attenzione